Edward was just a little boy when he was switched from regular classes to special ed. It was kindergarten, and he viewed the move as a big step up.
爱德华还是个小男孩时，就被从普通班调到了特殊教育班。那时他在上幼儿园，他把这次调动看作是一次重大的提升。
I thought it was cool because when you think of the word special meaning special, you know, like good, a good thing?
我觉得这很酷，因为当你想到“特殊”这个词意味着特别，你知道，比如好，一件好事？
Yeah.
是啊。
And, with my name being Edward, I thought it was kind of built for me.
而且，我的名字叫爱德华，我觉得这就像是为我量身定做的。
Oh. Like, Ed meant you?
噢。意思是“Ed”指的就是你？
Yeah.
是啊。
He was Ed. Of course he was going to special ed. And he didn't really figure out what special ed classes really meant for years, until one day in junior high school riding the school bus.
他叫Ed。当然他要去特殊教育班。他好多年都没弄明白特殊教育课到底意味着什么，直到有一天，他在上学的校车上。
And one of my friends, who was younger than me, on the bus, asked me to help him with his homework. And I noticed he had harder homework than we did.
我车上的一个朋友，他比我小，让我帮他写作业。我发现他的作业比我们的难。
Why? What do you remember about his homework?
为什么？关于他的作业你还记得什么？
Because he was doing like, I think it was, timetables and division-type things. And ours was addition and subtraction, still, and we were a couple of grades higher than he was. And the spelling words was like, they looked like high-schoolers would have a spelling word, kind of thing like, forbidden and probably some more words harder than that, kinda.
因为他在做，我想是乘法表和除法之类的东西。而我们还在做加减法，而且我们比他高几个年级。拼写单词看起来就像高中生会有的词，比如“禁止”之类的，可能还有比这更难的词。
Like the word forbidden. And what were you guys doing?
比如“禁止”这个词。那你们在做什么？
Cow, sheep, sleep. It kind of got me mad. And I just kind of thought we were all regular. And then, that day, I saw kind of like a divider kind of thing.
牛、羊、睡觉。这让我有点生气。我一直以为我们都是正常的。然后，那天，我看到了某种隔阂。
I would think that, that would be very hard.
我想那一定很难受。
Well, yeah, because you kind of think of yourself as regular until these teachers and people of high authority are telling you you're not the same as everybody else. So you have to figure out OK, so why am I different?
嗯，是的，因为你会一直认为自己是正常的，直到这些老师和权威人士告诉你，你和别人不一样。所以你必须弄清楚，好吧，那我为什么与众不同？
A lot of kids in junior high school and high school feel different. But to be told no, it's not your imagination, you are different? This moment is something a lot of kids in special ed get to at some point or another: a shocking moment of understanding that they are not the same as other kids and that everybody else knew that long ago. They knew it when they didn't.
很多初中生和高中生都会觉得与众不同。但如果是被告知，不，这不是你的想象，你确实与众不同呢？这个时刻是很多特殊教育班的孩子迟早会遇到的：一种震惊的理解，意识到自己和其他孩子不一样，而且大家都早就知道了。在他们不知情的时候，别人就已经知道了。
We were doing a project in first grade. Putting a snowman-- actually, we had to put cut-out objects, like cut-out circles, and put it on there, and put stuff on it.
我们在一年级做过一个项目。做一个雪人——其实，我们得把剪好的物体，比如剪好的圆圈，贴上去，再放点东西。
Holly is a high school student in Chicago. She's 18.
霍莉是芝加哥的一名高中生。她18岁。
And I was doing that. And I didn't cut one. And I accidentally unscrewed the top of the glue, and it spilled all over. So I had to clean it up. And then she put me in the corner and yelled at me. It was really embarrassing. Everybody was laughing. It was kind of hard. So that's the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] I really remember. I guess she thought I was stupid in some way. I felt bad about myself at that point because I realized that I really was different from everybody else.
我当时在做那个。我没剪好一个。我不小心拧开了胶水的盖子，胶水洒得到处都是。所以我不得不把它清理干净。然后她让我站在角落里大声训斥我。真的很尴尬。大家都在笑。那挺难受的。所以我真的记得那个[听不清]。我想她觉得我有点笨。在那一刻我对自己感觉很糟糕，因为我意识到我确实和别人不一样。
I was about, maybe, 14 when I was placed into a special ed class because my reading skills were real low.
我大概14岁的时候被分到了特殊教育班，因为我的阅读能力真的很差。
David is also a high school student here in Chicago. He's also 18.
大卫也是芝加哥的一名高中生。他也18岁。
When I was placed into the special ed program, you know, I felt sad and lonely. For me, a man, like I was a slow person that had problems learning, like a mentally problems.
当我被分到特殊教育项目时，你知道，我感到悲伤和孤独。对我来说，作为一个男人，就像我是个迟钝的人，有学习问题，就像有精神问题。
Today on our program, stories of people who were told that they're different: some who were comfortable with that, some who did not understand it, some who understood it and did not like it. We bring you stories of the developmentally disabled. It is a very different kind of show for us with voices and stories that usually do not make it to the radio.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述那些被告知与众不同的人的故事：有些人安于现状，有些人不理解，有些人理解了却不喜欢。我们为你带来残障人士的故事。这对我们来说是一档非常不同的节目，其中的声音和故事通常不会出现在广播里。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in three acts. Act One, Get On The Mic. In which we hear the story of what happens when you hand microphones to developmentally disabled people of various sorts and then send them out with camera crews to interview anyone they want on the streets of America. One thing that turns out to be on the minds of the disabled, same thing that's on your mind and mine, TV.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，拿上麦克风。在这一幕中，我们将听到当把麦克风交给各种残障人士，并派他们带着摄像组去采访美国街头任何他们想采访的人时，会发生什么。事实证明，残障人士关心的一件事，和你我关心的一样，那就是电视。
Act Two, Black Hole Son. In that story we hear from a mother and her son who, at three, became mesmerized with black holes and Stephen Hawking, an obsession which gave way to bunnies and flowers.
第二幕，黑洞之子。在那个故事中，我们听一位母亲讲述她的儿子，他在三岁时就对黑洞和斯蒂芬·霍金着迷，这种痴迷后来转向了小兔子和花朵。
Act Three, Walkout. Veronica Chater tells the story of her own brother, Vincent, who one day quit his job at an assisted learning center, and then quit everything else, mystifying everybody in his life. Stay with us.
第三幕，罢工。维罗妮卡·查特讲述了她弟弟文森特的故事，他有一天辞去了在辅助学习中心的工作，然后辞去了生活中所有其他的事情，让身边所有人都感到困惑。请继续收听。
Act One, Get On The Mic. Here's a typical moment from the film, How's Your News? The film is a documentary in which five developmentally disabled people travel across America in an RV interviewing people they meet along the way. When they get to Texas, one of the reporters, Sue Harrington, is at a cattle auction talking to an auctioneer, an older guy wearing a cowboy hat. There's all sorts of talk about prices and cows. And then Sue, apropos of absolutely nothing, comes out with this question.
第一幕，拿上麦克风。这是电影《你的新闻怎么样？》中的一个典型片段。这部电影是一部纪录片，五位残障人士乘房车穿越美国，采访沿途遇到的人。当他们到达德克萨斯州时，其中一位记者苏·哈林顿正在一家牲畜拍卖行，采访一位戴着牛仔帽的年长拍卖师。到处都在谈论价格和牛。然后，苏完全没头没脑地抛出了这个问题。
Sir, have you lately read any good books or seen any good movies that you could recommend to us?
先生，您最近读过什么好书，或者看过什么可以推荐给我们的好电影吗？
No, I ain't read any good books lately. I can't remember the name of the movie I saw the other day. I saw Message in a Bottle , and that was a dad gum good movie, I thought, kind of a tear-jerker.
不，我最近没读过什么好书。我不记得前几天看的电影名字了。我看了《瓶中信》，我觉得那是一部该死的好电影，挺催泪的。
Oh, really? Really? It's a good one? You know, that's the first good review I've heard for that one.
噢，真的吗？真的？那是一部好片子？你知道，这是我听到的关于那部电影的第一条好评。
Well, I'm kind of sentimental. I cried in Old Yeller too.
嗯，我这人比较多愁善感。看《老黄狗》我也哭了。
Now, How's Your News? team has an uncanny knack for bringing the sentimental out of people they meet. Arthur Bradford, who led the How's Your News? team across the country, he first got to know them in 1993 at a camp for disabled adults called Camp Jabberwocky. He was a counselor there teaching a video class. And as part of the class, he would take the campers out to do man-on-the-street interviews.
现在，《你的新闻怎么样？》团队有一种不可思议的本领，能引出他们遇到的人多愁善感的一面。亚瑟·布拉德福德，他带领《你的新闻怎么样？》团队走遍全国，他是在1993年的一个名为“Camp Jabberwocky”的残障成人夏令营中认识他们的。他当时是一位辅导员，在教视频制作课。作为课程的一部分，他会带学员们出去做街头采访。
They did that for a few summers, and then decided that it might be exciting and fun to try to do their interviews on a two-week, cross-country trip, which became this movie. Arthur says that, from the start, it's been interesting to see how people react to the disabled reporters.
他们那样做了几个夏天，然后决定尝试进行一次为期两周的全国巡回采访可能会很刺激、很有趣，这就成了这部电影。亚瑟说，从一开始，观察人们对这些残障记者的反应就很有意思。
What I've noticed is that, when someone with a disability approaches someone on the street, this is without a camera or anything, that person sort of settles into OK, I need to, I guess basically, talk down to this person. It's sort of like they're talking to a child, I would say. But what I like about when you give them a microphone and a camera is that, suddenly, the people take them a little more seriously. And I would say they, maybe, give them a little more respect.
我注意到的是，当一个残疾人走近街上的人时，这还是在没有摄像机之类的情况下，那个人会有一种“好吧，我想我基本上需要屈尊跟这个人说话”的感觉。可以说，就像是在和一个孩子说话。但我喜欢的一点是，当你给他们一个麦克风和一台摄像机时，人们突然会认真对待他们一点。我想说，他们也许会多给他们一点尊重。
Hello. My name is Ronnie. I'm from How's Your News? . What's your name, sir?
你好。我的名字是罗尼。我来自《你的新闻怎么样？》。先生，你叫什么名字？
Curtis.
柯蒂斯。
Curtie, who?
柯蒂是谁？
Tuldgrave.
塔德格雷夫。
What do you do, Curtie?
你做什么工作，柯蒂？
I work for the post office.
我在邮局工作。
Yeah? Tell us about the post office.
是吗？跟我们说说邮局吧。
The post office is a good place to work.
邮局是个工作的好地方。
Yeah? Yeah, I get my mail there at the post office. I love getting mail. Have you met any famous people?
是吗？我会在那儿收邮件。我喜欢收邮件。你见过什么名人吗？
No.
没有。
This reporter, Ron Simonsen, asks nearly everybody who he interviews if they've met any famous people, especially if they've met Chad Everett who used to star in Medical Center . Ron is a big Chad Everett fan and wears a homemade Chad Everett sweatshirt through parts of the film. Here's Ron interviewing a woman in Las Vegas.
这位记者罗恩·西蒙森几乎问他采访的每个人是否见过名人，特别是他们是否见过曾经主演《医学中心》的查德·埃弗里特。罗恩是查德·埃弗里特的超级粉丝，在电影的部分片段里还穿着自制的查德·埃弗里特运动衫。这是罗恩在拉斯维加斯采访一位女士。
I'm Ronnie Simonsen reporting from Las Vegas. Today, I'm with a fabulous singer, Jennifer Holloway. Tell me, Jennifer, how's it feel to be a singer?
我是罗恩·西蒙森，在拉斯维加斯报道。今天，我和一位了不起的歌手珍妮弗·霍洛威在一起。告诉我，珍妮弗，当歌手是什么感觉？
Fabulous. I enjoy it.
棒极了。我很享受。
Have you met any famous people?
你见过什么名人吗？
H I have: Tanya Tucker. I've met--
我见过：坦尼娅·塔克。我见过——
Have you met Chad Everett?
你见过查德·埃弗里特吗？
No, I have not.
不，我没见过。
You know who he is?
你知道他是谁吗？
Yes. Yes, I do.
是的，我知道。
I do an impersonation of Chad Everett.
我会模仿查德·埃弗里特。
Well, let's see it.
好啊，让我们看看。
All right. This is Chad Everett.
好吧。这是查德·埃弗里特。
OK.
好。
You've got class, lady. My name is Chad Everett. You know, I was the star of Medical Center.
你有品位，女士。我的名字是查德·埃弗里特。你知道，我是《医学中心》的主演。
There are moments during How's Your News? when things happen that, in another movie, might seem like they're mocking the people on camera. But, in this context, they don't, partially because it's clear how well the filmmakers know the reporters and love them. They were counselors and campers together in the RV. They've known each other for years, taking a road trip.
在《你的新闻怎么样？》中，有些时刻发生的事情在另一部电影里看起来可能会像是在嘲笑摄像机前的人。但在这种背景下，并非如此，部分原因是因为很明显制作人们是多么了解并热爱这些记者。他们是房车里的辅导员和学员。他们认识多年了，一起踏上公路之旅。
Two of the reporters, Sean and Bobby, have Down's Syndrome. Larry has a condition called Spastic Cerebral Palsy. The two most talkative reporters, Ron, who has Cerebral Palsy, and Sue, who has a mental disability, came into a studio to talk about the film. They brought along a guitarist, Chad Urmston, one of their counselors, to play some of the songs from the film.
其中两位记者肖恩和鲍比患有唐氏综合症。拉里患有痉挛型脑瘫。两位最健谈的记者，患有脑瘫的罗恩和有智力残疾的苏，来到录音室谈论这部电影。他们带了一位吉他手查德·厄姆斯顿，他是他们的辅导员之一，来演奏电影中的一些歌曲。
I began by asking Ron what his thing for Chad Everett is all about. It turns out Ron has been a fan ever since he was a kid, back when he was spending a lot of time in and out of hospitals, and Chad Everett was playing a doctor on TV.
我开始问罗恩他对查德·埃弗里特的痴迷是怎么回事。原来罗恩从小就是他的粉丝，那时他经常进出医院，而查德·埃弗里特在电视上扮演一名医生。
My mother and I wrote a letter to Chad Everett. My mother wrote a letter to him, and I dictated. And I named everything he'd been in, not just Medical Center, but everything: The Rousters, Hagen, every show that he was on. And he wrote me a note. He says life's not meant to be on reruns. He said, "God bless your life. Watch The New Love Boat, Chad."
我和我母亲给查德·埃弗里特写了一封信。我母亲写的信，我口述。我列举了他参演的所有作品，不仅仅是《医学中心》，而是所有作品：《硬汉》、《哈根》，他演的每一部剧。他给我回了张便条。他说人生不该只是重播。他说：“上帝保佑你的生活。看《新爱之船》，查德。”
Watch The New Love Boat? Is Chad Everett on The New Love Boat ?
看《新爱之船》？查德·埃弗里特演了《新爱之船》吗？
Well, he was a guest on there.
嗯，他是那里的客串嘉宾。
He was a guest star?
他是客串明星？
Yeah. Yeah. You know, like I'm a guest star on your show? He was a guest star on that show.
是啊。是啊。你知道，就像我是你节目的客串明星吗？他是那个节目的客串明星。
I see.
我明白了。
Oh, yeah. I want to tell them how we went to the set of General Hospital. Can I tell them that? I went to the set of General Hospital .
哦，是的。我想告诉他们我们是怎么去《综合医院》片场的。我可以告诉他们吗？我去了《综合医院》的片场。
What was that like?
那是什么感觉？
Oh, that was exciting. Wasn't it, Arthur? Want to get in here?
哦，那太令人兴奋了。不是吗，亚瑟？想参与进来吗？
Yeah. That was very exciting. We went to the set of General Hospital when we were in Los Angeles.
是的。那非常令人兴奋。我们在洛杉矶时去了《综合医院》的片场。
And I walked in that studio there, and the guy said, "What the hell are you doing here?" And I said I was a colleague of Monica Quartermaine's, I was a cardiac surgeon. Not really, but it's pretend I was a colleague of hers.
我走进那个摄影棚，那个人说：“你到底在这干什么？”我说我是莫妮卡·夸特梅恩的同事，我是心脏外科医生。不是真的，但假装我是她的同事。
Right. Did he laugh?
对。他笑了吗？
He laughed. He laughed. He thought that was funny.
他笑了。他笑了。他觉得那很有趣。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
He thought that was really funny, hilarious, though.
不过，他觉得那真的很有趣，令人捧腹。
Yeah.
是啊。
There's something about, the whole way across the country and then going to General Hospital, when you travel with someone like Ron, who is so excited about certain things, something about his enthusiasm rubs off on everybody else.
当你和罗恩这样的人一起旅行时，整个横跨全国的过程，然后去《综合医院》，他对某些事情如此兴奋，他的这种热情会感染其他人。
So, for instance, going to General Hospital , the set of General Hospital by myself, I'm not sure I would be so excited. But, with Ron, the whole way there, as we got closer and closer to General Hospital , he started clapping his hands and rocking back and forth. And you were just so excited about going to General Hospital.
所以，举个例子，如果我一个人去《综合医院》，去《综合医院》的片场，我不确定我会这么兴奋。但是，和罗恩一起，一路上，当我们离《综合医院》越来越近时，他开始拍手，来回摇晃。而你对于去《综合医院》真是太兴奋了。
I was because I wanted to see Leslie Charleson. And we're going to go back there again, in California. Maybe I'll see her again, then.
我之所以兴奋，是因为我想见莱斯利·查尔森。我们在加利福尼亚还得再去一次。也许到那时我能再见到她。
Well, let's let Chad come in, and let's have you sing.
好吧，让查德进来，我们让你唱首歌。
All right. Are we ready, Chad?
好。我们准备好了吗，查德？
OK, guys.
好了，伙计们。
All right. Let's do it.
好吧。我们开始吧。
Ron, and why don't you introduce this session?
罗恩，你为什么不介绍一下这段演出呢？
This is, today, we're singing my favorite state, California, and where we went to the set of-- to California-- all my celebrity friends. And I'm going to sing it now, for you, Ira.
这是，今天，我们要唱我最喜欢的州，加利福尼亚，以及我们去加利福尼亚片场——所有的明星朋友。现在我要为你唱这首歌，艾拉。
All right.
好吧。
Ready? One, two, three.
准备好了吗？一，二，三。
[GUITAR MUSIC]
[吉他音乐]
[SINGING] You'll never, never know. You'll never, never know. You'll never, never know what you have found. You'll never, never know. You'll never, never know. You'll never, never know what you have found.
[歌唱] 你永远、永远不会知道。你永远、永远不会知道。你永远、永远不会知道你发现了什么。你永远、永远不会知道。你永远、永远不会知道。你永远、永远不会知道你发现了什么。
[SINGING] California. Oh, California. Oh, California, oh, here I come. I went to the set of General Hospital . I met Leslie, met Leslie Charleson. I got to hold her, her Daytime Emmy, her Daytime Emmy at General Hospital .
[歌唱] 加利福尼亚。哦，加利福尼亚。哦，加利福尼亚，哦，我来了。我去了《综合医院》的片场。我见了莱斯利，见了莱斯利·查尔森。我握住了她的，她的日间艾美奖，她的日间艾美奖，在《综合医院》。
[SINGING] California, California. Oh, California, oh, here I go. California, California, oh, California oh, here I go.
[歌唱] 加利福尼亚，加利福尼亚。哦，加利福尼亚，哦，我走了。加利福尼亚，加利福尼亚，哦，加利福尼亚，哦，我走了。
Hi. My name-- oh. Hi. My-- oh. Hi. My name is Susan Harrington. Hi. Hi, would you like to be interviewed? Hi, can I interview you for How's Your News?
嗨。我的名字——哦。嗨。我的——哦。嗨。我的名字是苏珊·哈林顿。嗨。嗨，你想接受采访吗？嗨，我可以为了《你的新闻怎么样？》采访你吗？
Hey, Sue?
嘿，苏？
Yes?
什么事？
I've often been in the situation where I have to walk up to a stranger on the street with a microphone and a tape recorder, and I always get a little nervous. Do you get nervous?
我经常遇到这种情况，必须带着麦克风和录音机走到街上的陌生人面前，我总是会有点紧张。你会紧张吗？
Well, you can't do something like this and not have a little bit of nerves and butterflies in the stomach. Come on!
嗯，你不可能做这种事还不紧张，胃里没有蝴蝶在飞。来吧！
Do you find that it's hard, sometimes, getting people to talk to you?
你有没有发现，有时让人们跟你说话很难？
Yes. Sometimes it is hard because there are people who just will not talk to us. They're like, no way.
是的。有时确实很难，因为有些人就是不跟我们说话。他们就像，没门。
When we were at the camp, I think we chose the reporters for How's Your News especially because they seemed to be especially undaunted about going up to strangers and talking to them. In fact, if you were to see Sue in a crowd without a microphone, she just likes to go up to strangers and talk to them.
当我们在营地时，我想我们选择《你的新闻怎么样？》的记者，特别是因为他们看起来对于走向陌生人并与他们交谈特别无所畏惧。事实上，如果你在人群中看到没有麦克风的苏，她就喜欢走向陌生人并与他们交谈。
Like, a perfect example is, in the film, the [? assembly ?], and I'm interviewing this Mr. John B. Porterfield. And he was very difficult to talk to.
比如，一个完美的例子是，在电影里，那个[？集会？]，我在采访这位约翰·B·波特菲尔德先生。他很难沟通。
I should say, that interview happens in an alley in, what looks like, the kind of sketchy part of town, and Sue is visibly a little nervous.
我得说，那个采访发生在一条巷子里，看起来像是城里比较乱的地方，苏明显有点紧张。
Sir, good evening. Susan Harrington from How's Your News ? And we'd just like to ask you a few questions tonight.
先生，晚上好。我是来自《你的新闻怎么样？》的苏珊·哈林顿。今晚我们只想问你几个问题。
OK.
好。
Sir, what is your name?
先生，你叫什么名字？
John B. Porterfield. I am a combat war hero, and I'm living on the streets like a dog.
约翰·B·波特菲尔德。我是一个战争英雄，像条狗一样流落街头。
Are there times, Arthur, where you're looking through the camera at a moment like that, where you feel scared for them?
亚瑟，有没有什么时刻，你透过摄像机看着那一幕，你会为他们感到害怕？
Yeah. There were a lot of times when I'm sitting there watching and I'm thinking that I don't want anything to go wrong. I feel very protective. I was always worried about the explosion where someone would just be like, "What the hell are you doing here? I don't want to talk to this person." And so, in that particular interview, I was a little nervous.
有。有很多次我坐在那儿看着，心里想我可不希望出什么岔子。我感觉非常有保护欲。我总是担心会有爆发，某个人会像“你到底在这干什么？我不想跟这个人说话。”所以，在那个特定的采访中，我有点紧张。
What I'm asking you is, I'm from out of state, so is there anything you-- I mean, do you think there's anything we should see here that you've seen and you've liked?
我问你的是，我是外地来的，所以你觉得有什么我们应该看看，或者你见过并喜欢的吗？
I don't like this town. I'm going to tell you that right now. I've been beat up. I've been-- ah, I just want to forget it.
我不喜欢这个镇。我现在就要告诉你。我被揍过。我被——啊，我只想忘掉它。
Arthur, there are a lot of moments in the film where it seems like the reporters are standing there, and they're not exactly sure what to say next or what to ask next. Why not give them questions?
亚瑟，电影里有很多时刻，看起来记者站在那儿，并不确定接下来要说什么或问什么。为什么不给他们问题？
Well, we tried that. We tried making lists of questions for them to ask, and it just didn't work. It was so clear that they were just asking questions that had been given to them that there wasn't really anything very interesting about it. In fact, it came off as a little bit wrong, you know? I think everyone always asks about are you worried about this coming across as exploitation? And, of course. Of course I am. And we all were, so we had to figure out what was and what wasn't appropriate. And, ultimately, I really felt strongly that the questions needed to be coming from them.
嗯，我们试过。我们试着为他们列出要问的问题清单，但根本行不通。很明显，他们只是在问别人给他们的问题，这并没有什么有趣的地方。事实上，这看起来有点不对劲，你知道吗？我想每个人都会问，你是否担心这会被视为剥削？当然。我当然担心。我们都担心，所以我们必须弄清楚什么是合适的，什么是不合适的。最终，我非常强烈地认为，问题必须出自他们自己。
My name is Ronnie Simonsen. I'm from How Is Your News .
我的名字是罗恩·西蒙森。我来自《你的新闻怎么样》。
This is a guy, he's sitting on a truck. It's about halfway across the country.
这是一个家伙，他坐在卡车上。这大约是在穿越全国的中途。
Who's your favorite singer?
谁是你最喜欢的歌手？
I like Boston.
我喜欢波士顿乐队。
What does it say? Please Come to Boston? Is that the name of the song?
上面写着什么？《请来波士顿》？那是歌的名字吗？
Yeah, I believe that one of them is it.
是啊，我相信其中一个是。
Yeah, you want me to sing it with you?
是啊，你想让我和你一起唱吗？
Huh?
哈？
Want me to sing it with you?
想让我和你一起唱吗？
No. I don't--
不。我不——
[SINGING] Please come to Boston in the springtime. La, la--
[歌唱] 请在春天来到波士顿。啦，啦——
So, Ron, you do such a nice job with this guy. You know, it doesn't seem like he's all that interested in talking, and then you find stuff to talk to him about where it seems like he actually cares about it.
所以，罗恩，你跟这家伙相处得真好。你知道，他看起来并没有多大兴趣谈话，然后你发现了一些你们可以谈论的话题，看起来他真的关心。
Well, yeah, I had to do something to make him happy and to make me happy. I couldn't just sit there and say, "Hey, sorry pal."
嗯，是的，我得做点什么让他高兴，也让我高兴。我不能就坐在那儿说，“嘿，对不起，伙计。”
Can you sing?
你会唱歌吗？
No, I can't sing.
不，我不会唱歌。
Can you act?
你会演戏吗？
No.
不。
Oh. What can you do? What do you like to do? You must have some hobby you like to do.
哦。你会做什么？你喜欢做什么？你一定有什么喜欢的爱好。
Yeah. I like to ride a motorcycle.
是啊。我喜欢骑摩托车。
Yeah? What does it make you feel like when you ride a motorcycle? Does it make you feel like The Fonz?
是吗？骑摩托车让你感觉如何？让你觉得像方兹吗？
Yeah, sort of.
是的，有点像。
Do you like The Fonz?
你喜欢方兹吗？
Yeah, do you?
是啊，你喜欢吗？
Yeah. Want me to do an impersonation with The Fonz? I could act it out with you, pretend we're driving a motorcycle. Not really, but just role-play. I am The Fonz. I'm riding a motorcycle. Want to ride a motorcycle with me?
是啊。想让我模仿方兹吗？我可以和你一起演戏，假装我们在骑摩托车。不是真的，只是角色扮演。我是方兹。我在骑摩托车。想和我一起骑摩托车吗？
Yeah, might as well.
好，试一试吧。
Come on. Come. Vroom! Vroom! Vroom! Vroom! Vroom!
来吧。来。轰！轰！轰！轰！轰！
You all bring out a really nice side of people.
你们所有人展现了人们非常好的一面。
Well, yeah. Yeah. It all depends on the people.
嗯，是啊。是啊。这完全取决于人。
Where are you from?
你是哪里人？
New Hampshire.
新罕布什尔州。
New Hampshire?
新罕布什尔州？
Yeah. We're traveling across country. We're going to California.
是啊。我们正在进行全国巡游。我们要去加利福尼亚。
Oh. You like doing that?
哦。你喜欢那样做吗？
Sure. It's my biggest dream. What's your biggest dream?
当然。这是我最大的梦想。你最大的梦想是什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You must have something. You can't have anything if you don't have anything, right?
你肯定有什么梦想。如果你什么都没有，那你就什么都没有，对吧？
Yeah. I ain't never thought too much about it.
是啊。我从来没太想过这个。
One of the facts of life for many disabled adults is that they don't get around that much. Many live in group homes. Most of their contact is with other disabled people. They don't go around talking to able-bodied strangers. For most of the How's Your News ? team, this was going to be the first time traveling across the country. This was their first time traveling without their families so far from home for so long.
对于许多残障成年人来说，生活的一个事实是他们不怎么出门。许多人住在集体宿舍里。他们大部分接触的是其他残疾人。他们不跟身体健全的陌生人交谈。《你的新闻怎么样？》团队的大多数人，这是他们第一次进行全国旅行。这是他们第一次在没有家人的陪同下，离家这么远，这么久。
And in the months since the film was finished and shown on television, the whole How's Your News? team has flown to Europe, and Canada, and around the United States when the film has been screened at film festivals. At those screenings, they bring a band. They perform their songs live, on stage, and it pretty much brings the house down. People love them.
而在电影完成并搬上电视后的几个月里，《你的新闻怎么样？》整个团队已经飞往欧洲、加拿大，并在电影节放映时在全美各地巡回。在这些放映会上，他们会带一支乐队。他们现场表演歌曲，效果几乎是轰动性的。人们很喜欢他们。
In interviews with Sue and Ron, I kept asking them what all of this was like, how their lives had changed. I have to say, every time that I asked those, they were pretty nonchalant about it all, very low-key. Here's Ron, for instance.
在采访苏和罗恩时，我一直在问他们这一切是什么感觉，他们的生活发生了怎样的变化。我不得不说，每次我问这些问题时，他们都对此表现得很淡然，非常低调。比如罗恩就是这样。
Well, it's good. It's very good, and I felt really honored and blessed.
嗯，这很好。这非常好，我感到非常荣幸和受宠若惊。
In a separate interview with Arthur, I asked him about their reactions to these kinds of questions.
在与亚瑟的单独采访中，我问了他对这类问题的反应。
Yeah. It's funny because Ron, who is so celebrity obsessed, often gets asked how does it feel to be a celebrity now? And he just brushes that question off. You know, they've lived their lives. They're all 35, 40. I don't think that this process is going to actually radically change them.
是的。这很有趣，因为罗恩，那个名人痴迷者，经常被问到，现在成名了感觉如何？但他只是把那个问题挡开了。你知道，他们已经过上了自己的生活。他们都35、40岁了。我不认为这个过程真的会从根本上改变他们。
For some reason it seems like they just always expected that this would happen, that someone would pick them up and drive them across the country to make a movie.
出于某种原因，他们好像总是预料到会发生这种事，会有人把他们接走，开车带他们横跨全国去拍电影。
Wow.
哇。
I don't know. That sounds weird. But if you ask them, they're all kind of like, yeah, this is the way it was supposed to be. And they took it all in stride.
我不知道。这听起来很奇怪。但如果你问他们，他们都像是“是啊，这就是它本该有的样子。”他们泰然处之。
I think, as filmmakers and American TV viewers, we want there to be this big Olympic moment where they're just like, ta da! I feel so great and my life is so changed. And I do think that they had a wonderful time on this trip but, they didn't-- and I actually like it-- they didn't freak out and start weeping on camera or anything like that.
我认为，作为电影制作人和美国电视观众，我们希望有一个伟大的奥林匹克时刻，他们会像“哒哒！”我感觉太棒了，我的生活发生了翻天覆地的变化。我确实认为他们在这次旅行中玩得很开心，但是，他们没有——实际上我喜欢这样——他们没有抓狂或者在镜头前痛哭流涕之类的。
What you're making me realize is that my instinct in asking you, even this particular set of questions about this, is suddenly seeming very wrong.
你让我意识到，我问你，甚至是问这一组问题时的直觉，突然显得非常错误。
Well, I just didn't want this to be one of those disability documentaries where the music starts soaring, and everybody without a disability feels so good because they have helped these people.
嗯，我只是不希望这成为那种残疾纪录片，音乐开始高亢，而每个没有残疾的人都因为帮助了这些人而感觉良好。
By understanding them.
通过理解他们。
Right. The final scene in the movie is we all go swimming at the beach in the Pacific Ocean, in Venice Beach in California. And I do think there's a certain beauty to that. And they were just kind of whooping it up. And, honestly, when we were swimming in that beach, we were all there. We had made it across the country. We were exhausted, but there was a real feeling of accomplishment. The sun was setting, and I really felt this feeling of yes, we have done something here. We set out to do it. We made it across the country.
对。电影的最后一幕是我们都在太平洋的海滩上游泳，在加利福尼亚的威尼斯海滩。我确实认为那有一种美感。他们只是在大声欢呼。说实话，当我们在那片海滩游泳时，我们都在那里。我们已经横跨了整个国家。我们精疲力竭，但有一种真正的成就感。太阳正在落下，我真的感觉到了——是的，我们在这里做成了一些事。我们出发去完成它。我们完成了横跨全国的旅行。
I have to say I have to stop you there because I feel like we're getting to that big moment that you tried to avoid in the film.
我不得不说我必须打断你，因为我觉得我们正在达到你在电影中极力避免的那个大时刻。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, I know. I guess that's true.
是啊，我知道。我想那是真的。
Arthur Bradford, with Sue Harrington and Ron Simonsen from How's Your News? The movie aired on Cinemax and at film festivals. You can order your own DVD of the film at howsyournews.com.
亚瑟·布拉德福德，与来自《你的新闻怎么样？》的苏珊·哈林顿和罗恩·西蒙森。这部电影在Cinemax和电影节上播出。你可以在howsyournews.com订购你自己的电影DVD。
Chad, here we go.
查德，我们开始吧。
[SNAPS FINGERS]
[响指声]
One, two, three.
一，二，三。
[MUSIC - "THE GRAND CANYON" BY SUSAN HARRINGTON]
[音乐 - 苏珊·哈林顿的《大峡谷》]
[GUITAR MUSIC]
[吉他音乐]
[SINGING] The Grand Canyon was carved by the Colorado River. I learned this in history class. This is really an amazing thing because we are about to dig some history of our own as we have arrived at one of the seven wonders of the world. Beautiful. Beautiful. Beautiful. Beautiful. Beautiful. Beautiful. Take me there. How grand is this canyon? So deep and so wide. How grand is this canyon? So deep and so wide. How grand is this canyon?
[歌唱] 大峡谷是由科罗拉多河刻蚀出来的。我在历史课上学过这个。这是一件非常了不起的事情，因为我们要挖掘属于我们自己的历史，因为我们已经到达了世界七大奇迹之一。美。美。美。美。美。美。带我去那儿。这峡谷有多壮观？如此深，如此宽。这峡谷有多壮观？如此深，如此宽。这峡谷有多壮观？
Coming up, yet another three-year-old fan of physicist, Stephen Hawking. And Vinny drops out: assembly line not required. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，又一位物理学家斯蒂芬·霍金的三岁小粉丝。维尼退学了：不需要流水线。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
With This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that topic. Today's program, Special Ed, stories of developmentally disabled people. We have arrived at Act Two of our show.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为你带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目是“特殊教育”，关于残障人士的故事。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。
Act Two: Black Hole Son. Because of a very rare genetic disease, Sam was born with holes in several vital organs, including his heart and his brain. For his first five years, if one wasn't making his life hell, the other was. He's seven now. And recently his mom and he sat down together to talk about how things used to be and how they got much, much better.
第二幕：黑洞之子。因为一种非常罕见的遗传疾病，萨姆出生时几个重要器官都有孔，包括他的心脏和大脑。在他前五年的生活中，如果一个器官没有让他生活在水深火热之中，另一个就会。他现在七岁了。最近他和妈妈坐下来，谈论过去的生活以及他们是如何好转起来的。
OK. So let me start interviewing you.
好了。那么让我开始采访你。
All right.
好的。
Can you describe yourself? What kind of a person are you?
你能描述一下你自己吗？你是一个什么样的人？
I'm nice and kindful person.
我是一个善良、贴心的人。
You're kindful?
你很贴心？
Yes, and playful.
是的，而且爱玩。
What do you do that's nice?
你做了什么贴心的事？
Hug you.
拥抱你。
When I was pregnant with Sam, the first ultrasound came back that there was something wrong. I was thinking just please, let it be something with his body not with his brain. I can handle his body, but I'll be a bad mom to a retarded child. Everybody has their thing they can't take, and that's it for me.
我怀着萨姆时，第一次超声波检查显示有什么不对劲。我心想，请让这只是他身体的问题，而不是大脑的问题。我可以应对他的身体，但我会成为一个糟糕的母亲，养育一个智障的孩子。每个人都有他们无法承受的事，而这就是我的底线。
So when Sam was born, when he was five days old, he had heart failure. So then we learned about the deletion in the chromosome, velo-cardio-facial syndrome. So we didn't know if he was going to make it. And we had a talk with the geneticist. And he said if you give him the operations, it's not sure he'll pull through. But if he does, he's going to be retarded, probably. And I said OK. I don't care anymore. I want him, and I need him.
所以萨姆出生时，在五天大的时候，他心脏衰竭了。然后我们了解到了染色体缺失，即腭心面综合症。所以我们不知道他能不能挺过去。我们和遗传学家谈过。他说如果你给他做手术，不能保证他能活下来。但如果他活下来了，他可能会智障。我说好吧。我不在乎了。我想要他，我需要他。
What were you like when you were three years old?
你三岁的时候是什么样的？
I was walking, but I was crying too.
我会走路，但我也会哭。
Do you want to talk about what you used to be like?
你想谈谈你过去是什么样的吗？
No way.
绝对不行。
He started torturing animals when he was three, and talking all the time about wanting to die. And he stabbed his stepfather with a plastic knife and drew blood, and poured boiling water on me, wiped things on the bus that should not be wiped.
他三岁时开始虐待动物，整天谈论想要死。他用塑料刀刺伤了他的继父，弄出了血，把滚烫的水浇在我身上，在公交车上抹不该抹的东西。
He was kicked out of school when he was four because they said he was a danger to himself and others. And so we took him to a psych unit, and he was studied for a few days. And that's when they told us about the bipolar, rapid-cycling bipolar, which is common in velo-cardio-facial syndrome. It has early-onset, and it hits you hard a lot of the time. And sometimes it doesn't, but it did in him. But nobody told me that.
他四岁时被学校开除了，因为他们说他对他人和自己都有危险。所以我们把他带到心理科，他被观察了几天。就在那时他们告诉我们他患有双相情感障碍，快速循环型双相障碍，这在腭心面综合症中很常见。它有早发性，而且大部分时间会严重影响你。有时不会，但他发作了。但没人告诉过我这些。
I want to show you a drawing that you did.
我想给你看一张你画的画。
That's me with heart faces and heart eyes.
那是我，有心形的脸和心形的眼睛。
There's about 100 hearts in your face in this drawing.
这幅画里你的脸上大约有100个心。
Yeah.
是啊。
Green hearts, how come? What were you feeling when you drew this?
为什么是绿色的心？你画这张画时是什么感觉？
I was feeling like hugging you and kissing you and giving you cards.
我感觉想拥抱你，亲吻你，给你卡片。
All your drawings now have a lot of hearts and flowers and birds, and people are smiling. Do you remember, when you were about four years old, do you remember what you drew all the time?
你现在所有的画里都有很多心、花和鸟，人们都在微笑。你还记得你四岁左右时，你一直画的是什么吗？
What?
什么？
Black holes?
黑洞？
Yeah.
是啊。
Do you know what you were feeling when you were drawing black holes every day?
你知道你每天都在画黑洞时是什么感觉吗？
Like, the black hole was going to suck the whole world up and make everybody die and end of the world.
就像，黑洞要把整个世界吸走，让每个人都死掉，世界末日。
Yeah. Did you feel like that a lot, like everybody was going to die?
是啊。你经常有那种感觉吗，好像每个人都要死掉？
Yeah.
是啊。
I think the first time Sam heard of a black hole, he was almost four. And we were watching Stephen Hawking, a show. At that time, he couldn't sit down for anything. He couldn't sit down for a 15-minute cartoon. But he was really into space. And this was the only time he sat down and he watched the boring show from start to finish. They had, I think it was like a '50s cartoon of a black hole on just for a second, you know, one of those swirly things. That just captivated him. He started drawing it all the time. In every family portrait, it'd be us and the black hole.
我想萨姆第一次听说黑洞时，他快四岁了。我们在看一个关于斯蒂芬·霍金的节目。当时，他什么也坐不住。他连15分钟的卡通片都坐不住。但他真的很迷太空。这是他唯一一次坐下来，从头到尾看完了那个无聊的节目。我想那是一个50年代关于黑洞的卡通片，只放了一秒钟，你知道，那种旋转的东西。那让他着迷。他开始一直画它。在每一张全家福中，都会有我们和那个黑洞。
At school, they had this rainbow bear notebook and it would have all the kids' drawings in there. And there would be, like, 19 drawings of kids going sledding, kids going to McDonald's, kids playing with their siblings or something. And then, on Sam's page, it would be a black hole destroying the universe or a black hole coming down the railroad tracks sucking up humans. I was kind of proud of his differentness and his imagination, but, at the same time, I knew that it was like this horror to him.
在学校，他们有一个彩虹熊笔记本，里面会有所有孩子的画。里面会有比如19幅画是孩子们滑雪、去麦当劳、和兄弟姐妹玩耍之类的。然后，在萨姆的那页上，会是毁灭宇宙的黑洞或者在铁轨上过来吸走人类的黑洞。我有点为他的与众不同和想象力感到骄傲，但与此同时，我知道这对他是种恐怖。
What are some nightmares you've had?
你做过什么噩梦？
The moon, blowing moon.
月亮，吹气的月亮。
The moon blows on you?
月亮朝你吹气？
Yeah.
是啊。
How come?
怎么会？
I think of bad thoughts that time. I mean, bad thoughts.
那时候我有坏念头。我是说，坏念头。
You had bad thoughts and that's why the moon blew on you?
你有坏念头，所以月亮才朝你吹气？
Yeah.
是啊。
Did the moon know you had bad thoughts?
月亮知道你有坏念头吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
What would happen when the moon blew on you?
月亮朝你吹气时会发生什么？
I was scared and frightening.
我很害怕，很惊恐。
And you had that nightmare a lot, I think.
我想你经常做那个噩梦。
Two times.
两次。
No. Like a whole year you had that nightmare.
不。你做那个噩梦大概有一整年。
Before he discovered black holes, it was any swirling thing that sucks you in. Like, even when he was months old, if he saw a ceiling fan, it was the only time he would quiet. He would just stare at that ceiling fan. I know a lot of babies do, but he just was obsessed.
在他发现黑洞之前，任何旋转的东西都会把他吸进去。比如，甚至在他几个月大时，如果他看到吊扇，那也是他唯一安静的时候。他只是盯着那个吊扇。我知道很多婴儿都会这样，但他就是痴迷。
And then, when he was three, he had an imaginary friend, but it wasn't a boy, it was a fan. But this one was called bad, bad fan. And its blades were teeth. And then it had these little, tiny eyes and these little, tiny feet at the bottom, and it would kill people. It would just blow on people and that would kill them because his breath was filled with teeth. And then, sometimes when he broke things, he said bad, bad fan did it. And it was kind of creepy, you know? It was just me and him living in the house. And you start thinking-- oh.
然后，在他三岁时，他有一个幻想朋友，但不是个男孩，是一个风扇。但这个叫“坏坏风扇”。它的叶片是牙齿。然后它底部有小小的眼睛和脚，它会杀人。它会对着人吹气，那会杀死他们，因为他的呼吸里充满了牙齿。然后，有时他弄坏东西时，他说那是坏坏风扇干的。这真让人毛骨悚然，你知道吗？房子里就我和他。你开始想——哦。
He had to destroy all day long. He had to. He couldn't not. He destroyed his favorite toys. He destroyed my favorite furniture, anything that meant anything, especially.
他整天必须搞破坏。他必须这么做。他无法控制。他毁了他最喜欢的玩具。他毁了我最喜欢的家具，任何有意义的东西，尤其是。
And I used to watch The Sally Jessy Raphael Shows, or whoever it was that had all those shows about the out-of-control-- I think it was Montel-- had all the shows about the out-of-control, really young children. And the parents had to lock the door against them at night. And they lived in fear. And, supposedly, nobody could help.
我以前常看莎莉·杰西·拉斐尔秀，或者任何有关于失控孩子节目的节目——我想是蒙特尔——有所有关于失控的幼儿的节目。父母们不得不晚上锁上门防着他们。他们生活在恐惧中。而且据说没人能帮忙。
And I would always think well, you must be really bad parents. I would never have a problem with controlling my kid. I would teach them how to act. And if I had your kid for a week, he'd shape up. And so, of course, once I became afraid of my child, I didn't tell anyone because I thought they would think the same thing about me. And I kind of thought the same thing about me. You know, he'd be nice and normal, and then just do something so horrible and senseless.
我总会想，好吧，你们一定是糟糕的父母。我绝不会在控制孩子方面有问题。我会教他们如何表现。如果我照顾你的孩子一个星期，他就会变好。所以，当然，一旦我开始害怕我的孩子，我就没告诉任何人，因为我觉得他们也会那样看我。我也觉得自己也是那样。你知道，他本来很好很正常，然后突然做出一些非常可怕且毫无意义的事。
And it seemed like that to Sam too. He could never understand. He'd do something like try to break the cat's leg, something like that. And then, immediately afterwards, he'd be crying and saying, "I don't know why I did that." And he would be just as angry and sad as I was. And he'd say, "I don't understand." And he'd start punching himself and biting himself and putting bruises all over his body. Ugh! Oh, that was a horrible life.
这对萨姆来说也是一样。他永远无法理解。他会做比如试图折断猫的腿之类的事。然后，在那之后，他会立刻哭着说：“我不知道我为什么要那样做。”他会和我一样愤怒和悲伤。他说：“我不明白。”然后他开始打自己、咬自己，身上到处都是淤青。呃！哦，那真是糟糕透顶的生活。
Do you know why you take the pills every day?
你知道你为什么要每天吃药吗？
Because my brain is all, like that.
因为我的大脑全是，像那样。
What is that? Nobody can see on the recorder. Describe it.
那是什么？录音机上没人能看到。描述一下。
It's so wild. And has to-- it's pumping blood all wild.
它太疯狂了。必须——它在疯狂地抽血。
Pumping blood all wild?
疯狂地抽血？
Yeah.
是啊。
He started on a drug called Zyprexa. And within 24 hours we noticed a change. And then, after about 56 hours, it was like night and day. This was not the same kid at all. It's hard to believe that we were all living like we were. I mean, I can't believe it. When I sit here and talk about it, I can't believe that that existed and I didn't try to get a diagnosis earlier. I just kept on thinking I could not be such a bad parent and it would get cured. Or, I don't know what I thought.
他开始服用一种叫再普瑞萨的药。不到24小时我们就注意到了变化。然后，大约56小时后，简直是天壤之别。这根本不是同一个孩子了。很难相信我们所有人都过着那样的生活。我是说，我简直不敢相信。当我坐在这里谈论它时，我不敢相信那是真的，我居然没有早点寻求诊断。我一直以为我不可能是一个那么糟糕的家长，他会好起来的。或者，我不知道我在想什么。
But, within two days after starting on the Zyprexa, we would go out. We could go to do three errands in one day. He could wait in line. He was doing well in school. I mean, it didn't happen overnight because he still at some bad memories, but he started to get some nice memories to put on top of the bad ones. And he just got nicer and nicer, and happier and sweeter. He stopped having nightmares. At first, he would ask me when his brain was going to be messed up again, but now he feels like it's his brain, you know? He feels like he's in control of his own brain.
但是，开始服用再普瑞萨两天后，我们就出去了。我们一天能办三件差事。他能排队。他在学校表现很好。我是说，这不是一夜之间发生的，因为他还有一些不好的记忆，但他开始有一些美好的记忆来覆盖坏的记忆了。他变得越来越好，越来越快乐，越来越甜美。他不再做噩梦了。起初，他会问我他的大脑什么时候会再次变坏，但现在他感觉那是他的大脑，你知道吗？他觉得他在掌控自己的大脑。
Do you have any girlfriends?
你有女朋友吗？
Yeah, only one. Who is it? Rose.
有，只有一个。是谁？罗斯。
Aw. Tell me about Rose.
噢。跟我说说罗斯。
She's kind and cute.
她很善良，很可爱。
What does she look like?
她长什么样？
I forget.
我忘了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
She looks kind of like her mom, maybe.
她长得有点像她妈妈，也许。
Would you like to be married?
你想结婚吗？
Yeah! I would like to be.
想！我想结婚。
What is marrying like?
结婚是什么样的？
You have a bride. And you are giving them flowers and heart and Valentines stuff.
你有新娘。你会给她们花、心形的东西和情人节礼物。
When I was doing these interviews with him, I realized something about him that I hadn't seen before, which is all those hearts and bunnies and rainbows that he talks about all the time, it's not because he's silly. It's because he's been through more pain and powerlessness than most people ever will in their whole life. And I think he took all that information about life, about what it is, what it means for him to be alive, and he made an informed decision that he's going to be happy with the good parts of life and he's going to spread them around. And I think he knows something about hearts and bunnies and rainbows. He's not like Forrest Gump, you know? It's not like-- you know, he came out of something very hard, and he has a very strong will.
当我和他做这些采访时，我意识到他身上的一点我之前没看到的，那就是所有那些他整天谈论的心、兔子和彩虹，那不是因为他傻。而是因为他经历的痛苦和无助比大多数人一生都要多。我认为他吸收了关于生活的所有那些信息，关于它是如何，对他来说活着意味着什么，然后他做出了一个明智的决定，他要享受生活中的美好部分，并且要把它们传播出去。我认为他懂一些关于心、兔子和彩虹的事。他不像阿甘，你知道吗？不是那样——你知道，他从非常困难的事情中走出来，他有着非常坚强的意志。
Let's make up a story about a bad boy.
让我们编一个关于坏男孩的故事。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] boy?
[听不清] 男孩？
Sure.
好啊。
No. That'd scare people out.
不。那会吓跑人的。
That would scare people listening?
那会吓到听众吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Let's make up a story about a human boy. What would he do in the day?
让我们编一个关于人类男孩的故事。他一天会做什么？
He would just have fits. And then he would [UNINTELLIGIBLE] his bowl, and then he would spill it, like that.
他只会发脾气。然后他会[听不清]他的碗，然后他会把它洒掉，就像那样。
Push his bowl of food away and spill it?
把食物碗推开并洒掉？
Yeah.
是啊。
What else?
还有呢？
Break the bowl. And his mom will say, "You have to clean it up. And, after that, you will have to go right up to your room."
打碎碗。然后他妈妈会说：“你得把它清理干净。之后，你得马上回你的房间。”
What would the boy be thinking?
那个男孩会怎么想？
That he wants to be a nice boy. Then when he came back downstairs, he hugged everyone in the world. The end.
他想做一个好男孩。然后当他回到楼下时，他拥抱了世界上每个人。完。
Wow. That bad boy turned out to be a good boy. Do you know anyone like that?
哇。那个坏男孩最终变成了好男孩。你认识这样的人吗？
No. It's fake.
不。那是假的。
The mother who put that story together asked that we not broadcast her and her son's name.
组织这个故事的母亲要求我们不要广播她和她儿子的名字。
[MUSIC - "KEEP THE SUNNY SIDE" BY THE WHITES]
[音乐 - The Whites的《保持阳光的一面》]
Act Three, Walkout. Sun Kim has taught severely autistic children for the past five years. She says autistic kids, in general, tend to not understand social cues, and that her students, because of the severity of their autism, can't tell her their basic needs or thoughts. And so she finds she spends a lot of her work day trying to figure out what it is that they're thinking. And often, she's stumped.
第三幕，罢工。孙金教严重的自闭症儿童已经五年了。她说自闭症儿童通常不理解社交暗示，而她的学生因为自闭症的严重程度，无法告诉她他们的基本需求或想法。所以她发现她每天工作的时间里，都在努力弄清楚他们在想什么。而且经常，她会被难住。
Sometimes you'll just see them looking off in the distance and laughing. You think what are they laughing about? What's so funny? Or when we ask them to do certain things, like pass out the place mats or pass out the cups, what's going through their head process? Like, OK, I'm supposed to do this and I don't-- or are they hearing just, murmur, murmur, verbiage, and not really understanding? Or just listening to the tonalities of what we're saying? Believe me, I've wanted to be inside their head just to know what they're thinking or feeling so many times.
有时你会看到他们看着远方傻笑。你心想他们在笑什么？什么这么好笑？或者当我们要求他们做某些事情时，比如分发餐垫或分发杯子，他们脑子里在想什么？比如，好吧，我应该做这个，我没做——或者他们听到的只是murmur，murmur，文字，并没有真正理解？或者只是在听我们说话的语调？相信我，我有多少次想钻进他们的脑袋里，只是为了知道他们在想什么或感觉什么。
This question, of course, was part of our story in Act Two. And it's at the heart of this next story. It's at the center of what it means to deal with certain kinds of people with developmental disabilities.
这个问题，当然，是我们第二幕故事的一部分。它处于下一个故事的核心。它处于处理某些类型的残障人士的含义的核心。
Veronica Chater's younger brother, Vincent, can't do math, even the simplest addition. He doesn't speak well. He has a version of what used to be called mental retardation. But, when he was a baby and doctors tried to diagnose him, they couldn't find anyone else with his particular combination of symptoms, and so they named his own syndrome after him: the Vincent syndrome.
维罗妮卡·查特的弟弟文森特，不会算术，甚至连最简单的加法都不会。他说话也不流利。他患有一种曾经被称为智力迟钝的变体。但是，当他还是个婴儿，医生试图诊断他时，他们找不到任何有他那特定症状组合的人，所以他们用他的名字命名了他的综合症：文森特综合症。
He's an adult now. And for a while seemed to be doing just fine, until a point a few years ago when he surprised everybody in the family by quitting his job, and then quitting everything else in his life. And it was not clear to them why he did it and what it meant and what it would mean for his future. Veronica Chater put together this story.
他现在是个成年人了。有一段时间他似乎做得很好，直到几年前的某一点，他让家里所有人都大吃一惊，辞去了工作，然后辞去了他生活中所有的一切。对他们来说，他不辞而别的原因，以及这意味着什么，对他的未来意味着什么并不清楚。维罗妮卡·查特组织了这个故事。
Ever since Vincent quit his job, he spent more and more time alone in his room. At Christmas, at our parent's house in northern California, my brothers and sisters and I weave in and out of the kitchen, talking about work, telling jokes, and taking orders from Mom.
自从文森特辞职后，他在房间里待的时间越来越多。在北加州我父母家过圣诞节时，我和我的兄弟姐妹在厨房里穿梭，谈论工作，开玩笑，听妈妈指挥。
There are 11 of us. I'm the second oldest. Vinnie's the fifth. As usual, he's nowhere to be seen. When I go down the hall, I find him in his bedroom with the door closed, drinking an orange soda from the can and watching an old movie.
我们有11个。我是老二。文尼是老五。照常，他不见踪影。当我走到走廊时，我发现他在卧室里，门关着，喝着罐装橙味苏打水，看着老电影。
[SOUND OF TELEVISION]
[电视声音]
His face is close to the TV screen, about 10 inches away. And he has a serious expression, the kind you catch on a detective who's trying to crack a case. He could be 18 and he could be 50, you can't quite tell. He has a short little boy haircut. And, every day, he wears a sweatshirt with the words carpe diem on it. The truth is, he's 34.
他的脸离电视屏幕很近，大约10英寸远。他表情严肃，那种你在试图破案的侦探脸上看到的表情。他可能18岁，也可能50岁，你没法分辨。他留着短小的男孩发型。每天，他都穿着一件印着“及时行乐”字样的运动衫。事实是，他34岁。
Did Santa come and fill your stocking?
圣诞老人来装满你的长袜了吗？
Indeed.
当然。
What did you get in your stocking?
你的长袜里有什么？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Jamaroonie.
[听不清]。Jamaroonie（乱语）。
Some jamaroonies?
一些Jamaroonies？
Vinnie still lives in his childhood bedroom, which he calls his apartment. Ever since he retired, bit by bit, he's been withdrawing into his own little world, a world that doesn't include me or anyone else.
文尼仍然住在他的童年卧室里，他称之为他的公寓。自从他退休以来，一点一点地，他一直在退回到他自己的小世界里，一个不包括我或任何人的世界。
OK, here we go. Cleaning up.
好了，我们要开始了。清理。
My mom and dad still take care of Vinnie, but it's mainly my mom's job.
我的父母仍然照顾文尼，但这主要是妈妈的工作。
Clean it, clean you.
清理它，清理你。
Well, we'll shave you, shave you.
嗯，我们要给你刮胡子，刮胡子。
My parents, who are devout Roman Catholics, were undaunted by the idea of having a, so-called, special needs child. They figured it was part of God's plan. He was an angel in our midst, as my dad always said. They refused to think of him as a burden, even though he would depend on them for the rest of their lives. Every morning, my mom readies him for the day: combing and gelling his hair, brushing his teeth, and shaving him.
我的父母是虔诚的罗马天主教徒，他们对有一个所谓的“特殊需求”孩子并没有感到气馁。他们觉得这是上帝计划的一部分。他是一个在我们中间的天使，正如我爸爸总是说的那样。他们拒绝把他看作是一个负担，尽管他余生都要依靠他们。每天早上，妈妈为他准备好新的一天：梳头并涂发胶，刷牙，刮胡子。
[SINGING] I like my clean-shaven man.
[歌唱] 我喜欢我那个刮得干干净净的男人。
She tilts his chin this way and that, handling him like a barber with an overbooked schedule.
她把他的下巴歪来歪去，像一个预约过满的理发师一样处理他。
Done. All spiffed up for the day. OK, here.
好了。今天打扮得帅气利落。好了，给你。
Here we go.
我们走吧。
Put your shaver away, OK?
把你的剃须刀收好，好吗？
There are all sorts of little games that Vinnie and my mom play together all day long. Most of them are impenetrable to outsiders. He'll say, "Repeat. Repeat." And she'll reply, "Redeep in the redeep." And they'll both giggle.
文尼和妈妈整天都在玩各种各样的小游戏。大多数对外人来说是深不可测的。他说：“重复。重复。”她会回答：“Redeep in the redeep。”然后他们都会咯咯笑。
OK, so I'm going to test you. I want to see if you know any movies because you're always the one that knows movies. OK. Who said this? Who's the one that sucked his thumb and said, "Mommy"?
好了，我要考考你。我想看看你知不知道什么电影，因为你总是那个懂电影的人。好。谁说了这个？那个吸着拇指说“妈妈”的人是谁？
The cartoon Robin Hood.
卡通片《罗宾汉》。
Right. You got that one. I didn't know if you were going to get that.
对。你答对了那个。我不知道你能不能答上来。
Despite his disability, Vinnie has a really good memory for all sorts of trivia. Quizzing him about movies is the impromptu game my mom and dad play with him throughout the day, from morning till night.
尽管有残疾，文尼对各种琐事记忆力非常好。考考他关于电影的问题是爸爸妈妈整天从早到晚跟他玩的即兴游戏。
OK, I've got one for you, Vincent. See if you can get this one. [SINGING] It was a Monday. Ain't gonna soldier no more.
好了，我有一个问题考你，文森特。看看你能不能答上来。[歌唱] 这是一个星期一。不再当兵了。
The bond between them is more than a bond, it's a union for life. As Vinnie passed through his teenage years and became an adult, Mom saw to it that he was kept busy. She signed him up for bowling, for Special Olympics, and for pretty much every seasonal sport from basketball to badminton.
他们之间的纽带不仅仅是纽带，这是一种终身的联合。当文尼度过青少年时期成为成年人后，妈妈确保他一直很忙。她为他报名参加保龄球、特奥会，以及从篮球到羽毛球几乎所有的季节性运动。
But as he got older, Vinnie's personality grew darker and more mysterious. I didn't notice it right away. I don't think any of us did. Mom was so good at keeping Vinnie distracted from himself that it didn't seem like a problem. But two years ago, it grew too large to ignore.
但随着年龄增长，文尼的个性变得更加阴暗、神秘。我没有立刻注意到。我想我们谁都没注意到。妈妈一直很擅长让文尼从自我中转移注意力，所以这看起来不成问题。但两年前，它长得大到无法忽视了。
Let's play games.
玩游戏吧。
I'm not playing games right now. Go get my sour cream. Come on. I want the sour cream. I can't make those chantilly potatoes without it.
我现在不玩游戏。去拿我的酸奶油。来吧。我要酸奶油。没有它我做不了那些尚蒂伊土豆。
Every time I go home, it hits me a little bit more that, even though Vincent and I are about the same age, my mom talks to him like he's a precocious four-year-old. And, more and more, I've noticed that he's aware of it too. When he returned without the sour cream and noticed that Mom and I were talking about him, he got upset.
每次我回家，我都会越来越强烈地感觉到，尽管文森特和我差不多大，但我妈妈跟他说话就像他是个早熟的四岁孩子。而且，我越来越注意到他也意识到了这一点。当他没拿回酸奶油，注意到妈妈和我正在谈论他时，他很不高兴。
It is a wonderful reaction to talk about somebody? When you talk about me, I wonder.
谈论某人是种美妙的反应吗？当你谈论我时，我也在想。
I talked right in front of you. I wasn't telling any secrets. I'm going to say what I'm going to say because it's true. There's nothing wrong with having the truth, is there?
我当着你的面谈论的。我没说任何秘密。我要说我要说的，因为这是真的。说真话没什么错，对吧？
I'll put this away here--
我把它放在这儿——
You know, where it goes. Top shelf. The little slot, slide it in there. Thank you, very much.
你知道它该放在哪儿。顶层架子。那个小槽，滑进去。非常感谢。
No.
不。
He can go from one minute to-- oh, yeah. Dad's so afraid he's going to get him angry, he won't give him any orders. I have to give all the orders. Yeah. If he wants to get smart with me, and I say, "God said you have to obey your parents I'm your mother. You do what I say, when I say. Da, da, da, da, da. Da, da, da, da." And he'll do something, sometimes I say, "You go in and you tell God you're sorry for that." He'll go in his room. And he comes out, "Sorry for talking like that." And I said, "That's fine, Vin. OK. We just don't do that." Then he gets in a really good mood after that.
他可以从一分钟到——哦，是啊。爸爸太怕他生气了，不敢给他下任何命令。我必须下所有命令。是啊。如果他想跟我耍聪明，我说：“上帝说你必须顺从你的父母，我是你的母亲。你按我说的做，在什么时候。达，达，达，达，达。达，达，达，达。”有时他会做些什么，我说：“你进去告诉上帝你因为那个道歉。”他会进他的房间。他出来时，“对不起，刚才那样说话。”我说，“那很好，文。好。我们只是不那样做。”之后他心情就会很好。
It might seem like my mom is rough on Vinnie, but I have to say that her way of dealing with him has pretty much worked out for the best, until the day Vinnie decided to retire. When he quit his job, Vinnie dropped everything including bowling, basketball, and the Special Olympics. Where once he was busy from dawn till dusk, now he had nothing to do, so he began sleeping to pass the time, up to 18 hours a day. It worried all of us, especially Mom. He was sleeping his life away, and we didn't understand why. It felt like we were losing him, like he was giving up, so I set out to figure out why.
妈妈对文尼可能看起来很粗暴，但我必须说，她处理他的方式基本上算得上是最好的，直到文尼决定退休的那天。当他辞掉工作时，文尼丢弃了一切，包括保龄球、篮球和特奥会。曾经他从早忙到晚，现在他什么也不用做，所以他开始通过睡觉来打发时间，一天睡长达18个小时。这让我们所有人都很担心，尤其是妈妈。他在睡觉虚度光阴，我们不明白为什么。感觉我们正在失去他，感觉他正在放弃，所以我开始着手弄清原因。
If you ask Vinnie about why he quit his job, you don't get much of an answer. In general, it's hard to get a direct response out of him on any subject. "Could be," he'll say, or, "Maybe." It's not clear he even knows what his own feelings are sometimes. Often, when any of us asks him about his job, he'll just change the subject, like he did when I asked him about it, sitting in Mom's kitchen.
如果你问文尼为什么要辞职，你得不到什么答案。一般来说，很难从他那里得到任何主题的直接回应。“可能是，”他说，或者，“也许。”有时甚至不清楚他自己是否知道自己的感受。通常，当我们中任何一个人问他关于工作的问题时，他就会转移话题，就像我在妈妈厨房里问他时那样。
How come you don't just tell me why you quit?
为什么你不告诉我你为什么要辞职？
But seriously, it might be empty, blank there, after you were saying something.
但说真的，它可能是空的，空白的，在你说了些什么之后。
You mean you're leaving that section blank because you don't want to fill it in with words?
你是说你把那部分留空了，因为你不想用词填满它？
Blank is there before I finish words.
空白就在那，在我说完话之前。
Are you playing word games with me now?
你现在在跟我玩文字游戏吗？
No.
不。
We've all asked Vinnie dozens of times in dozens of different ways why he quit his job and everything else. And every time his answer is just as cryptic, and so we're all forced to guess what the real reasons are. My mom's best guess is that Vinnie put himself into early retirement and started all these dark moods because of a chemical change in his brain.
我们所有人都无数次以各种方式问过文尼为什么要辞职和其他一切。每次他的回答都同样晦涩，所以我们被迫猜测真实原因。妈妈最好的猜测是，文尼让自己进入了提前退休状态，并开始所有这些阴郁的情绪，是因为他大脑中的化学变化。
The psychologist said he thinks there was a chemical imbalance that took place, suddenly, in his brain. And he prescribed Prozac for him.
心理学家说他认为大脑中突然发生了一种化学失衡。他给他开了百忧解。
Well, it's all chemical.
嗯，这都是化学问题。
I don't know. It's really a mystery to me what happened there.
我不知道。那儿发生了什么对我来说真是个谜。
Vinnie had worked for 12 years at a place called Concord Support Services, a company that hires mentally retarded adults and vocationally trains them. Vinnie always told me that he liked his job. He'd sit in a big warehouse with about 70 other disabled adults doing light assembly or stuffing envelopes. He made up to $60 a month, which, to him, was an infinite amount of money. We all assumed he'd found his place in the world.
文尼在一个叫康科德支持服务的地方工作了12年，这是一家雇佣智障成人并对他们进行职业培训的公司。文尼总是告诉我他喜欢他的工作。他会坐在一个大仓库里，和大约70个其他残障人士一起做简单的组装或装信封。他一个月最多能挣60美元，对他来说，这是一笔无限多的钱。我们都以为他在世界上找到了自己的位置。
Then, gradually, he started to become impatient and angry at work, threatening to break people's fingers if they touched him. He started disappearing into the work bathroom for up to an hour at a time just to get away from people. It was pretty clear that he was in a crisis.
然后，逐渐地，他在工作中开始变得急躁和愤怒，威胁说如果有人碰他，他就折断他们的手指。他开始消失在工作间的洗手间里，一待就是一小时，只是为了避开人们。很明显他处于危机之中。
On his last day, he was wandering around looking for a bead he'd dropped. His supervisor asked him what he was doing. One thing led to another. Vinnie lost his temper. My parents were called in for a meeting. And Vinnie quit, just up and walked out.
最后一天，他四处走动寻找掉落的珠子。他的主管问他在做什么。事情一发不可收拾。文尼发火了。我的父母被叫去开会。文尼辞职了，就那样站起来走了。
A few months ago, I asked Vinnie if he'd like to go back to his old job for a visit hoping it might spark something. I wasn't sure how he'd react, but he didn't even hesitate. He told me that he'd love to go. So the next morning, after my mom spiffed him up, we drove the route he'd taken for 12 years. When we arrived at the front doors, he's all smiles. He seems genuinely glad to be there.
几个月前，我问文尼是否想回原来的工作岗位看看，希望那能激发点什么。我不确定他会有什么反应，但他甚至没有犹豫。他告诉我他很乐意去。所以第二天早上，妈妈帮他打扮好后，我们沿着他走了12年的路线行驶。当我们到达前门时，他满脸笑容。他看起来真的很高兴来到这里。
Hi.
嗨。
I remember you.
我记得你。
You do? Nice to see you.
你记得？很高兴见到你[？简？]。
But, as we approach the warehouse floor where Vinnie used to work, his pace slows. At the warehouse door, he hesitates and purses his lips together.
很高兴见到你。
Hi.
但是，当我们靠近文尼过去工作的仓库地板时，他的脚步慢了下来。在仓库门口，他犹豫着，把嘴唇抿在一起。
How are you?
嗨。
Wonderful. Hi. Nice to see you [? Jane. ?]
你好吗？
Nice seeing you.
棒极了。嗨。很高兴见到你[？简？]。
He becomes shy and looks confused as one person after another comes up to him. Some touch him fondly, one man blows in his face, and everyone stares. Vinnie tries to appear cool, but I can tell he's tense.
很高兴见到你。
We miss you, Vinnie. We miss the Vinnie Arnold we knew. We missed you, Vinnie. We missed you.
当一个人接一个人走近他时，他变得害羞并看起来很困惑。有些人亲切地摸他，一个人对着他的脸吹气，大家都在盯着看。文尼试图表现得很酷，但我能看出他很紧张。
Would you like to begin basketball practice Saturday?
我们想你，文尼。我们想念我们认识的文尼·阿诺德。我们想你，文尼。我们想你。
I don't know. I'm not into-- I'm back into bowling and running again.
你星期六想开始篮球练习吗？
We hang out. And Vinnie looks uncomfortable, except when he decides, on his own, to busy himself cleaning and straightening. After 15 minutes, he disappears into the bathroom, his old hiding place. After a while, he comes out for a few minutes, then goes back in, and then comes back out again. When he heads back into the bathroom for the third time, I know it's time to leave.
我不知道。我没兴趣——我又重新开始打保龄球和跑步了。
Later, I talked to my brother, Danny, about it. Of all my siblings, Danny spends the most time with Vinnie. They go to movies, take walks, go to bookstores. Danny thinks Vinnie might have quit his job for all the normal reasons any of us quit a job. Maybe it had nothing to do with his disability.
我们逛了逛。文尼看起来很不舒服，除了当他决定自己动手清理和整理时。15分钟后，他消失在洗手间里，那是他以前的藏身处。过了一会儿，他出来几分钟，又回去了，然后又出来了。当他第三次回到洗手间时，我知道是时候离开了。
I think he was probably extremely bored working in this place, doing the same thing over and over again: stuffing envelopes, putting paper clips in bags. There was no challenge to it, and I think it really frustrated him.
后来，我跟弟弟丹尼谈了这件事。在我所有的兄弟姐妹中，丹尼和文尼待的时间最长。他们去看电影、散步、去书店。丹尼认为文尼辞职的原因可能和我们任何人辞职的原因一样正常。也许这和他的残疾毫无关系。
Vinnie might have simply had enough, enough of other people controlling his life. All the adults in his life were doing the sensible things you do for disabled people: giving structure to his days, coaxing his moods, all with the best intentions. It's possible that, in the end, that wasn't enough of a life. And so, one day, he changed the one thing in his life that he could. He said no to the one thing he could say no to and quit his job, and then quit everything else.
我认为他可能在那个地方工作感到极其无聊，一次又一次地做同样的事情：装信封，把曲别针放进袋子里。这毫无挑战性，我认为这真的让他很沮丧。
Being told what to do constantly, day in, and day out. And then he watches his other brothers and sisters running around and traveling and having their freedom, and here he is, stuck at home in his room. I can just imagine how frustrating that would be. It would make me angry if I was in that situation.
文尼可能只是受够了，受够了别人控制他的生活。他生活中的所有成年人都以最好的意图做着对残疾人来说理所当然的事：为他的日子建立结构，安抚他的情绪。最终，这可能并不是一个完整的生活。所以，有一天，他改变了他生活中唯一能改变的一件事。他对唯一能说不的事情说了不，辞去了工作，然后辞去了其他一切。
After Vinnie retired, my mom and dad were determined to get him back into some kind of routine. After meeting with all sorts of social workers and suggesting dozens of ideas to Vinnie, they finally came up with something that he agreed to. They hired my brother, Bernard, to build a chicken coop in the backyard and to put Vinnie in charge of a miniature chicken farm. My mom had always wanted a chicken farm anyway. This was her big chance to get one.
被不断地告知做什么，日复一日。然后他看着他的其他兄弟姐妹四处奔波，旅行，享受他们的自由，而他却被困在家里自己的房间里。我能想象那是多么令人沮丧。如果我处于那种情况，我会很生气。
Vinnie took to every aspect of chicken farming. He was painstakingly mindful of the chicken's daily schedule of free-range feeding and lock-up. And he was especially fastidious about coop hygiene. But more than that, to everyone's surprise, he started participating in activities again. He started basketball practice. And he's training again for the Special Olympics.
文尼退休后，妈妈和爸爸决心让他重新回到某种日常生活中。在和各种社会工作者会面并向文尼建议几十个想法后，他们终于想出了一个他同意的方案。他们雇我弟弟伯纳德在后院建了一个鸡舍，让文尼负责一个小型养鸡场。妈妈一直想要个养鸡场。这是她开一个养鸡场的好机会。
Molly, Polly, Jeanette, and Lonnie, here.
文尼投入到了养鸡场的方方面面。他非常细心地管理着鸡的每日自由放养喂食和锁进鸡舍的时间表。而且他对于鸡舍卫生特别讲究。但不仅如此，令大家惊讶的是，他又开始参加活动了。他开始练习篮球。他正在为特奥会训练。
[CHICKEN CACKLE]
莫莉、波莉、珍妮特和罗尼，在这儿。
Pretty much at any time of the day, you can see Vinnie standing as still as a marble sculpture in the backyard beside the coop, his eyes half closed, and his palms cupping the breeze, thinking, or just listening to the sound of his hens. He named them after old friends and talks to them like children.
[鸡鸣声]
[CHICKEN CACKLE]
差不多在一天中的任何时候，你都能看到文尼像一座大理石雕塑一样站在后院鸡舍旁，眼睛半闭着，双手拢着微风，思考，或者只是听着他的母鸡的声音。他用老朋友的名字命名它们，并像对待孩子一样与它们交谈。
Molly, Polly, Jeanette and Lonnie.
[鸡鸣声]
[CHICKEN CACKLES]
莫莉、波莉、珍妮特和罗尼。
Veronica Chater lives in Berkeley, California. She has a memoir coming out about her family next spring called, Waiting for the Apocalypse .
[鸡鸣声]
[MUSIC - "9 TO 5" BY HAMMOND STATE SCHOOL PERFORMING GROUP]
维罗妮卡·查特住在加利福尼亚州伯克利。她明年春天将出版一本关于她家庭的回忆录，名为《等待天启》。
This cover of 9 to 5 was recorded in 1985. It's the Hammond State School Performing Group in Louisiana. They are developmentally disabled kids in a music therapy program.
[音乐 - 哈蒙德州立学校表演组的《9到5》]
Our show today was produced by Jonathan Goldstein and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr and Starlee Kine. Senior Producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Maria Schell.
这个《9到5》的翻唱版本录制于1985年。这是路易斯安那州哈蒙德州立学校表演组。他们是音乐治疗项目中的残障儿童。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
我们今天的节目由乔纳森·戈尔茨坦和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔和斯塔利·基恩参与。高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。托德·巴赫曼和玛丽亚·谢尔提供制作帮助。
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to old shows online, for free. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
[鸣谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费获取我们的每周免费播客或在线收听往期节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this message for America.
[资助鸣谢]
God bless your life. Watch The New Love Boat.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他给美国带来这样的信息。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
上帝保佑你的生活。看《新爱之船》。
PRI. Public Radio International.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。